15 pounds of pure muscle a strict diet
and jaw-dropping fight training here's
how Michelle Rodriguez pushed herself to
the limit to embody that badass
Barbarian Dungeons and Dragons honor
among Thieves has arrived and treated
fantasy fans to a thoroughly enjoyable
modern interpretation of the popular
role-playing game the cast for the
latest iteration includes Chris Pine
reggae Jean page and Hugh Grant as a
barred Paladin and Rogue respectively
with Michelle Rodriguez playing the
Barbarian Holger Kilgore giving physical
and action-packed Blockbusters isn't A
New Concept for Rodriguez but this movie
came with a serious training regimen
thanks to the intensity of her Warrior
character the F9 actor revealed to the
mirror that the work required for her
role put her body through the ringer she
stated I had to train for three months
before gained 15 pounds of muscle and
then it's another five months of
maintaining that muscle we're gonna need
strength you got this right I know you
don't the actor's Spears commitment to
the physicality of her roles dates back
to her first film in 2000 sports movie
Girl Fight you know they say Love Kills
in the ring
since then she's become an established
action star thanks to the Fast and
Furious franchise and other high octane
flicks
would you believe I knocked him out with
my charm
you need that Charming
but her training regimen for Dungeons
and Dragons honor among these was
particularly tough speaking about her
training for the film in an interview
with the mirror Michelle Rodriguez
characterized her prep by sharing I have
never had that much discipline in my
entire life five days a week
weightlifting fight training
choreography it was rough in an
interview with denim geek the actor
added further context to her practicing
for the part when asked if she had a
background in martial arts Rodriguez
said she didn't but joke that all of the
muscles she gained to play holga made it
appear otherwise I find irony as a blade
because he who wields it most especially
you're not a lot of fun are you he also
spoke about how fight scenes can
sometimes hinder creating a good
sequence because it's easy to get lost
in the physicality of the moment which
she works hard to overcome in addition
to the rigorous physical demands
Rodriguez had to undergo a strict high
protein diet this seemingly only made
her more up for playing the role however
as it helped her become stronger and
more energetic she explained I was
pretty hardcore we were shooting during
covid and it was locked down in Northern
Ireland I had asked him for a punching
bag because holga really got to me could
kiss you try it
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
certainly doesn't deprive viewers of
action and spectacle and some of the
scenes were a challenge to bring to life
for the people involved during her
interview with denim geek Michelle
Rodriguez said that one of hulga's big
fight sequences was particularly
difficult according to Rodriguez she had
to work with a fight choreographers and
stunt teams for a month to bring the
sequence to life but the hard work paid
off and the actor credited the team for
their efforts in helping her sane they
did a wonderful job training five people
to do their sequences and shooting at
the same time Gladys on our side film
govers can see for themselves and the
actor's Fierce commitment to her
character paid off Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves is currently playing
in theaters
thanks
[Music]